[Musique]
e
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle singer view on voudrait avoir
vos raisonnements questionnements et
peut-être prose ce que vous voulez
concernant la géopolitique l'énergie et
les rapports de force autour de ces
questions là on va commencer à notre
gauche nous avons nicolas meilhan bons
joueurs ayant présentez-vous
succinctement donc je suis consultant en
stratégie sur les secteurs du transport
et de l'énergie depuis plus d'une
dizaine d'années et en dehors de ses
activités je fais partie de deux groupes
de réflexion d econoclaste et
l'association pour l'étude du pic
pétrolier à ce pauvre france je vous
demanderais de passer la parole à votre
votre gauche
bonjour francis perrin je dirige une
société qui s'appelle stratégie
politique énergétique et je suis le
directeur de la rédaction de
publications pétrolières et énergétiques
notamment pétrole et gaz arabes et la
lettre aux ag africain francis passer la
parole à votre voisin de gauche
bonjour philippe sibille lopez je suis
directeur fondateur du cabinet géo
polliat cabinet spécialisé en stratégie
et intelligence économique
est dédié aux questions
pétrolières gazières
énergétique de façon plus générale
accessoirement l'auteur d'un ouvrage sur
la géopolitique du pétrole qui s'appelle
géopolitique j'ai mal plus le team mais
avec un s parce que il ya plusieurs
géopolitique les plus en premier lieu
voilà alors on va garder la parole avec
philippe qu'est ce que vous entendez par
plusieurs points de vue dans la
géopolitique du pétrole c'est à dire et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser il
ya plusieurs mois une analyse en termes
géopolitiques de la situation pétrolière
on peut se baser tout simplement sur des
questions de grands ensembles de
quantité de normes
alors qu'au fond chaque pays qui soit
consommateur au producteur a sa propre
stratégie qui n'est pas nécessairement
celle du voisin l'occasion d'en reparler
j'imagine
francis perrin francis qu'est ce que
vous pouvez me dire de la stratégie de
l'arabie saoudite en ce moment
actuellement et depuis quelques mois
d'ailleurs mais ça va en croissant et en
embellissant si je puis dire
ce qui domine la stratégie saoudienne
c'est l'obsession de l'iran ce n'est pas
évidemment complètement nouveau bien au
contraire mais la montée en puissance de
l'iran où cette perception de la montée
en puissance de l'iran la levée
partielle des sanctions dont bénéficie
l'iran depuis le mois de janvier 2016 le
fait que l'iran veuille augmenter sa
production pétrolière ses exportations
pétrolières en 2016 donc à voir
évidemment plus de recettes au delà sa
production gazière ses exportations
gazières tous ces éléments la latitude
de la numération obama par rapport à
l'iran par rapport à l'arabie saoudite
tous ces éléments là et quelques autres
font que en arabie saoudite les
dirigeants sont très très inquiets par
rapport à l'iran et qu'ils ont décidé de
rendre coup pour coup et cela influe
directement sur leur stratégie
pétrolière qui traditionnellement été
une stratégie qui n'étaient pas
spécifiquement spécialement politisé
entre guillemets on a vu le 17 avril
2016 la réunion de doha au qatar entre
18 pays producteurs la plupart des pays
membres de l'opep l'organisation des
pays exportateurs de pétrole quelques
pays non opep dont la russie ces pays
devaient s'entendre sur un gel de leur
production en 2016 pour faire remonter
les prix du pétrole c'était une réunion
qui était préparé depuis plusieurs
semaines normalement il ne devait pas y
avoir de problème particulier est
quasiment à la dernière minute
l'arabie saoudite a dit non à un accord
sur le gel de sa production sur la base
du raisonnement de l'argument suivant si
l'iran ne gèle pas sa production nous
arabie saoudite nous n'allons pas gêner
notre production chacun savait que
l'iran n'accepterait jamais de geler sa
production puisque lire on a vu sa
production chuter depuis des années du
fait des sanctions occidentales
alors maintenant qu'il a enfin
l'occasion d'augmenter sa production il
ne va pas la gelée
donc dire s'imposer cette condition
c'était garantir les chèques le fiasco
de la réunion de doha ce qui est arrivé
il n'y a pas eu d'accord et c'est ce
point
particulièrement important souligne à
quel point la politique pétrolière
aujourd'hui de l'arabie saudite pas hier
ou avant hier mais aujourd'hui est entre
guillemets contaminés influencé par sa
perception d'une menace croissante lié à
la montée en puissance de l'iran qu'est
ce que vous pensez du fait que les
entreprises ben laden licencie 77000 de
leurs employés et que
l'arabie saoudite et les pays de la
région
commencent à s'organiser autour de fonds
d'investissement pour l'après pétrole
alors les fonds d'investissement dans
cette région ce n'est pas une nouveauté
le koweit a été le pionnier il ya très
longtemps sur les fonds souverains
absolument tout à fait et les autres ont
suivi émirats arabes unis qatar arabie
saoudite sous différentes formes avec
différents noms mais on parle bien ici
de fonds souverains donc ça ce n'est pas
nouveau dans cette région du golfe ce
qui par contre est nouveau c'est
l'annoncent par le prince mohammed bin
salman qui est donc l'un des fils du roi
kelmiz la défense qui est le vice
président y est qui est le président du
conseil des affaires économiques et du
développement donc on conçoit que c'est
un homme assez puissant simplement à cet
énoncé de ces quelques principales
fonctions un plan à long terme jusqu'à
horizon 2030 vision 2030 pour l'arabie
saoudite
il ne s'agit pas de se placer comme on
l'a souvent dit dans l'après pétrole
parce que les saoudiens savent très bien
qu'en 2030 il y aura encore beaucoup de
pétrole chez eux et ailleurs il s'agit
de diminuer de viser à diminuer la
dépendance du pays par rapport au
pétrole ce qui est très différent et ce
qui est tout à fait logique de la part
d'un pays producteurs parce que est très
dépendant du pétrole c'est une force
mais c'est aussi une fragilité c'est un
facteur de vulnérabilité notamment quand
les prix chutent comme ça a été le cas
depuis l'été 2014
c'est une vision ambitieuse elle a été
adopté par le conseil des ministres donc
ce n'est pas seulement la vision du
prince mohammed bin salman il l'a fait
adopter par les autorités saoudiennes
alors ensuite bon 2030 c'est à la fois
court et est loin en matière d'énergie
il peut se passer beaucoup de choses
est-ce que ce plan sera couronnée de
succès personne ne peut le dire
aujourd'hui ce qui est intéressant ce
sont quand même les grandes orientations
diversifie diversification dans le
secteur énergétique avec montée en
puissance du gaz et des énergies
renouvelables
ce qui est nouveau pour l'arabie
saoudite les énergies renouvelables et
puis diversification en dehors du
secteur de l'énergie avec le secteur
minier l'arabie saoudite a un vrai
potentiel dans ce domaine là avec la
fabrication d'équipements industriels
avec les industries de la défense avec
le tourisme tourisme autre qualité ça va
pas devenir la costa brava ça c'est
clair c'est pas le c'est pas le style de
la maison
donc voilà c'est cet intéressant cette
prise de conscience des objectifs
chiffrés derrière cette vision il ya un
ensemble de stratégies qui devront être
définis dont une stratégie pour la saudi
aramco la plus grande compagnie
pétrolière mondiale qui sera privatisée
sans doute à hauteur de 5% c'est-à-dire
pas grand-chose mais 5% ça peut faire
100 milliards de dollars pour alimenter
ce fonds souverain qui existe déjà le
public investment fund qui à quelques
centaines de milliards déjà à son actif
mais qui devrait passer à 1800 1900
milliards de dollars d'actifs à horizon
2030 et devenir le plus important fonds
souverain au monde selon donc cette
vision 2030 de l'arabie saoudite
philippe qu'est ce que vous percevez de
la stratégie saoudienne est ce que la
famille al saoud est connecté dans l'air
du temps par rapport aux grands enjeux
géopolitiques
la géopolitique de l'arabie saoudite
reposer
jai vue pas du coin ici en 1945
signé à bord du croiseur du même nom
kunis et sur
un soutien indéfectible et une relation
très soutenue entre états unis arabie
saoudite le les termes étaient simples
les états unis garantissait le maintien
sur le trône de la famille al saoud en
échange d'un pétrole bon marché
parce que pour ça que c'est est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est pour ça que la
famille al saoud mais son opposition sur
la
lah disclosure la publication la
diffusion à des 28 pages concernant le
rapport sénatorial contre sur le 11
septembre ces fameuses 28 pages à 750
milliards de dollars ben oui alors c'est
sûr ce rapport
il est clair que les saoudiens sont pas
rentrer dans le détail ils ont
simplement mis en garde l'administration
américaine en disant attendait si vous
nous poursuivent et enfin si vous
permettez aux tribunaux américains de
juger la responsabilité du gouvernement
saoudien dans les attentats du 11
septembre on va retirer une partie de
nos avoirs en dollars aux états le
volume de l'investissement de laon
saoudien c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliards de dollars lui d'anciens du
pib peut-être j'ai pas le chiffre exact
donc je préfère pas dire de bêtises
simplement
là encore c'est une promesse on va dire
au fond de vin ou une menace de dupes
parce qu'au fond c'est l'intérêt de
personne
quel est l'intérêt cki personnes
jeudi au dîner saoudien ni des
américains d'accor parce que le dollar
chuterait et les importations et les
exportations saoudiennes de pétrole se
font en dollars mais est ce que ça
arrangerait pas les états unis que le
dollar chute
pour l'instant et il a plutôt tendance à
chuter dégrade donc
j'ai pas jusqu'à le faire chuter si vous
espérez une remontée des taux comme le
prévoit j'aime et yolaine le président
de la réserve fédérale faut pas non plus
que votre monnaie se dévaluer se
déprécie trop trop brutalement donc là
encore c'est un petit peu de mon point
de vue de la gesticulation et il n'en
sortira pas grand chose par contre je
voulais revenir sur ce que disait jésus
francis
concernant la stratégie justement où les
stratégies des grands acteurs donc
francis a mentionné la réunion de doha
du 17 avril il y avait eu une réunion
auparavant en février
surtout entre la russie et l'arabie
saoudite pour justement préparer seuls
deux doigts du 17 avril et il s'était
mis plus ou moins d'accord pour geler
leur production au niveau de janvier
2016 en gros
ce qui a été moins 10 et qu'au fond les
deux pays en janvier 2016 avait déjà
fortement augmenté leur production ce
qui fait qu'en fait gelé une production
qui a déjà augmenté par rapport au mois
de janvier de l'année précédente c'est
un demi engagement certains sont même
gérer aller jusqu'à penser que
finalement il s'agissait de faire une
petite place à l'iran
qu'on m'explique n'en suis pas sûr du
tout
et si on revient là encore à cet
accord
on s'aperçoit que la russie et l'arabie
saoudite sont en compétition ultra
intensive pour approvisionner les
marchés et préserver le para de marché
alors attendez il faut savoir qu'ils
attaquent ou et est donc donc les
saoudiens essaie de se positionner en
europe parce que les russes et c'est à
eux de se positionner en asie intermedia
leurs compagnies pétrolières à
l'exportation c'est tout
donc les saoudiens depuis plusieurs mois
ont vendu aux raffineurs européens du
brut à prix discount pour essayer de
conquérir des parts de marché 3 qui et
quel prix le principal marché
d'exportation de la russie aujourd'hui
que le prix du discount c'est quelques
dollars par baril sais pas répond 1% du
prix du baril actuellement il a combien
de 45 sa future des pensions parce
qu'ils le vti du brent ces fourchettes
la 40 45 parce que c'est un peu remonté
donc il ya cette espèce de compétition
en termes de part de marché entre la
russie et l'arabie saoudite et il se
trouve précisément que ce sont les deux
principaux pivot d'un éventuel accord
mondial
c'est pour ça que l'iran aujourd'hui est
dans une utilisation qui est pas très
facile et surtout si l'iran de respecter
ce qu'elle souhaite faire c'est à dire
augmenter sa production
peut-être bon paraît qu'aujourd'hui déjà
en quelques mois ils augmentaient 300
mille barils jour de production par
rapport à avant les sanctions leurs
mains leurs marges de manoeuvre au
niveau de la production sait combien ces
2011 by
bon c'est pas bien parce qu'il faut du
temps et puis il faut des
investissements et puis ça dépend de
l'état des infrastructures après des
années d année à margaux donc peut
prétendre les iraniens que en un an il
pourrait augmenter d'un million de
barils jour ce qui semble peut-être un
petit peu optimiste par contre 300 à 500
mille barils jour très probable où ils
peuvent les faire donc il faut quand
même trouver de la place pour ces cinq
cent mille région additionnel alors
qu'on a déjà un marché qui est
relativement bien approvisionné
je voulais ajouter autre chose justement
sur social rivalité
russo saoudienne iranienne en gros
américano-russes
américano-russes encore autre chose le
pacte du quincy l'accord tacite entre
les saoudiens et les américains je
dirais que les saoudiens sont simplement
la pointe de diamant énergétique des
etats-unis non pardon là la pointe de
diamant des états unis au niveau
énergétique du mois l'allié parfait
énergétique cve les états unis il ya
plusieurs façons les etats unis c'est
pas monolithique les partis républicain
et démocrate ont pas nécessairement ou
en tout cas à l'intérieur de ces partis
vous avez des clans des factions qui
sont farouchement hostiles aux saoudiens
on a vu qu'elle a du temps de jeu me
suis en bouche les néoconservateurs une
partie des néoconservateurs je rappelle
qu'elles innovent et néo conservateurs
sont en fait des démocrates qui ont
quitté le parti démocrate pour rejoindre
les républicains et qui eux ont des
positions très souvent pro israélienne
et au moment les attentats du 11
septembre ils ont décidé que la relation
avec l'arabie saoudite ne pouvait plus
être ce qu'elle était par le passé que
l'arabie saudite n'était plus un allié
de confiance et qu'en plus c'est bon et
il y risquait de les pointer un de
préjudice aux intérêts israéliens dans
la région voire de soutenir des
mouvements qui je vous ouvre une
parenthèse nicolas meilhon qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire de tout ça là je
vais revenir peut-être sur le point de
vue énergétique de l'arabie saoudite ce
qui est intéressant avec le fonds
souverain qui qu'ils ont annoncé les
investissements dans l'énergie c'est
qu'en fait il nous montre la voie c'est
l'arabie saoudite qui nous montre la
voie de la transition énergétique il ya
un autre pays producteur de pétrole qui
qui qui nous montre la voie ça s'appelle
la norvège ils ont aussi un fonds
souverain à 800 milliards de dollars et
c'est le premier pays qui fait des
investissements pour se débarrasser de
sa dépendance
propre au pétrole un exemple oslo en
2019 ils ont prévu d'interdire la
circulation des voitures à oslo l'arabie
saoudite était un des derniers pays à
produire son électricité avec du pétrole
tous les autres pays suite aux deux
chocs pétroliers avait remplacé le
pétrole soit part du gaz soit part du
nucléaire et donc effectivement ils font
baisser la part d' de pétrole dans leur
production d'électricité ils limitent au
maximum leurs auteurs consommation pour
pouvoir augmenter au maximum leurs
exportations et puis il ne leur a pas
manqué que l'arabie saoudite et dans un
pays où le climat est très chaud et très
ensoleillé donc ça fait beaucoup de sens
par exemple de faire des énergies
renouvelables des panneaux solaires du
solaire thermique couplé avec des
générateurs au gaz pour limiter au
maximum leurs leur leur consommation de
pétrole donc ça c'est quand même un
paradoxe qui est assez intéressant à
souligner l'autre point c'est sûr la
russie l'arabie saoudite il ya quelque
chose qui s'est passé en début d'année
la russie est devenue le premier
fournisseur de pétrole de la chine
devant l'arabie saoudite qui était le
premier historiquement le premier pays
fournisseur de la chine pour quelle
raison parce que les russes ont accepté
de se faire payer leur pétrole mais
yoann yoannn et donc ça c'est un
changement assez significatif je pense
qu'il faudra surveiller justement
l'arabie saoudite qui est attaqué sur
ses propres terres sur la chine qui se
défend sur sur l'europe ce sera
intéressant de voir comment cette
situation va évoluer parce
qu'effectivement la demande de pétrole
aujourd'hui elle vient de deux pays elle
vient de la chine et le lien de l'inde
l'âne qui commencent à s'équiper en
voitures et qui va avoir un partenariat
privilégié aussi avec l'iran et c'est
probablement d'ailleurs leur premier
leurs premiers clients
francis nous l'europe on se positionne
comme un haut niveau de tous cet
échiquier géo politique énergétique
comment se comportent l'union européenne
voire même la france
par rapport à cette dépendance et ses
jeux géopolitiques
alors l'union européenne s'est dotée en
février 2015 d'une d'un projet qu'on
appelle le projet d'union énergétique
évidemment février 2015 et un petit peu
moins d'un an après
le début de la nouvelle où l'actuelle
crise russo ukrainienne la crimée l'est
de l'ukraine et il ya donc évidemment un
lien de cause à effet important entre
ces événements géopolitiques et cette
décision de l'union européenne d'adopter
ce projet d'union énergétique qui sera
mis en oeuvre sur plusieurs années
cette stratégie énergétique elle vise en
particulier le gaz naturel parce que
l'un des grands problèmes que l'on
ressent dans l'est dans les capitales
européennes en tout cas certaines
d'entre elles et à bruxelles c'est la
dépendance de l'union européenne par
rapport au gaz russe
et il est donc prévu de diversifier les
approvisionnements de gaz européens de
gaz il est prévu de développer le gaz
naturel liquéfié
qui permet d'avoir du point de vue des
pays importateurs une plus grande marge
de manoeuvre le gaz on l'exportent soit
par gazoduc soit sous forme de gaz
naturel liquéfié transporté sur des
bateaux des méthaniers un gazoduc par
définition c'est un lien fixe entre un
point de départ un point d'arrivée donc
il ya une rigidité
le gaz naturel liquéfié ce sont des
bateaux et à bateaux ça peut aller dans
un port et puis ça peut changer de
destination aller vers un autre rapport
tant que dans ce port de destination
il y a des installations de réception et
de regazéification du gaz naturel
liquéfié donc développer le gaz naturel
liquéfié ça permet ça permettrait à
l'europe donc d'avoir plus de marge de
liberté par rapport à 6 fournisseur
développer également les liaisons
gazière au sein de l'union européenne
dans certains cas vous avez vous pouvez
avoir certains pays qui vont avoir un
problème de pénurie de gaz ou de pénurie
potentielle de gaz lequel d'autres qui
sont bien dotés notamment les pays
d'europe centrale et orientale d'autres
qui sont bien dotés mais s'il n'y a pas
de liaison entre ceux qui ont du gaz et
ceux qui risquent de ne pas en avoir
assez au sein même de l'union européenne
on a une situation qui est évidemment un
peu absurdes ou au sein d'une union
union normalement ça veut dire quand
même un minimum de solidarité ce qui
pourrait aider certains autres pays ne
le peuvent pas parce qu'il n'a pas les
infrastructures de transport donc les
gazoducs donc développer le marché
intérieur de l'énergie en développant
les liaisons entre les pays où rien
l'équivalent d'une smart grid
énergétique oui tout à fait et puis
faire en sorte que les gazoducs
fonctionne dans les deux sens on a
construit des gazoducs russie vers
l'europe donc ça allait de l'est vers
l'ouest puisque la russie c'est
évidemment le premier exportateur
mondial de gaz avec gazprom l'union
européenne est très dépendante par
rapport au gaz importé donc logiquement
faisait des gazoducs dans le sens est
ouest mais si sur une partie de ses
gazoducs on se donne la possibilité qui
est possible techniquement d'avoir des
échanges de gaz dans les deux directions
on a donc par exemple l'allemagne ou la
france qui pourrait renvoyer du gaz y
compris du gaz russe vers d'autres pays
de l'union européenne qui pourrait en
manquait donc un ensemble de choses
diversification énergétique également
montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables plus d'efficacité
énergétique visant à rendre l'union
européenne à l'avenir ont des dents le
moyen-long terme évidemment moins
dépendante de possibles crise
énergétique notamment de crises qui
pourraient toucher ou de tensions qui
pourraient toucher les relations entre
l'union européenne et la russie et dans
le contexte de la crise russo
ukrainienne
c'est évidemment une hypothèse qui à
bruxelles au niveau de la commission
européenne est à une hypothèse fortement
cela plusieurs scénarios et qui a
évidemment dans toutes les têtes
philippe on a parlé de gazoducs
d'oléoducs et de choses comme ça
maintenant on va parler de la syrie
et il y a certains points qui sont
soulevées sur internet concernant le
soutien de la russie à la syrie pour des
questions de gazoducs des oléoducs ou de
transport énergétique qu'est ce que vous
pouvez me dire dessus à ce que c'est
vérifié ses véritables est-ce que c'est
simplement qu'est ce que vous en pensez
l'essentiel des gisements pétroliers
syriens sans dans l'est or less c'est
pas la région que contrôle le mieux le
pouvoir du régime assad le régime assad
est plutôt dans l'ouest contrôlent les
principales villes d'al azhar a vite
laissé conquérir alep
la zone franc à
la façade méditerranéenne
donc c'est pas une question de l'eau du
je ne pense pas
une gazoduc d'ailleurs palmyre qui est
un site historique comme chacun sait je
pense qu'il en reste il ya aussi oui
enfin il apparemment il n'en reste pas
mal
mais il ya aussi deux paniers vous avez
des gisements de gaz là on en a pas
beaucoup parlé mais bon j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit
une des priorités du régime assad donc
mais c'est peut-être une des priorités
russe dad de pouvoir imposer son propre
les audits pour l'union européenne
non parce que là
ce serait pour a promis la fin pour
acheminer quel gaz en provenance de quel
pays
le fermer arbres chicchi raid l'iran à
travers le l'irak et rejoindrait la
syrie il faudrait qu'ils traversent des
zones qui nécessairement seront pas très
très
favorables au régime assad quelle que
soit l'issue on sait pas quelles
échéances du réglement de la crise
syrienne règlement il ya un jour et on
sait pas dans quel terme donc si vous
avez des cures par exemple qui
contrôlent le nord par où ils vont
passer l'eau des aqueducs je vous donne
pas beaucoup de chance de survie
donc vous voyez c'est pas
là on tire des plans sur la comète sans
avoir le moindre
élément ferme de réflexion par contre
c'est dans la théorie de déficit en cpt2
bon on peut toujours imaginer ça mais le
plus simple serait quand même que ça
parte de l'iran que ça passe par la
turquie etc directement en europe
puisque la turquie est quand même malgré
les les
laisser
les interrogations qu'on peut avoir sur
la politique d'erdogan sourire de gars
ne sera pas éternelle non plus quoi
qu'on dise bon travail devant l'aja
c'est sûr non mais en même temps c'est
quand même plus simple d'avoir un seul
pays
de transit
pour le gaz iranien
plutôt que d'avoir à repasser par ce
moyen-orient très compliqué et notamment
l'irak où là encore les choses ne sont
pas réglées du tout ce qui aura un
kurdistan indépendant à terme n'en sais
rien
les kurdes de syrie bas cette même
question
que vont devenir les islamistes qui eux
sont plutôt dans le centre de la syrie
voire des ge où on vient on reviendra
sur les islamistes jouent et nicolas
médian ajouter quelque chose oui sur le
l'histoire des gazoducs qui a quand même
une histoire assez intrigante si on
s'intéresse un peu à la région n'a parlé
du gaz iranien des iraniens partage le
plus grand champ de gaz au monde avec
les qatari qatari qui sont deux
premières exportateur de gaz naturel
liquéfié
et donc les qatari quand il exporte ce
gaz naturel liquéfié qui coûte plus cher
un qui coûte 10 $ du dollar de mbt eu
les prix aujourd'hui en europe c'est
plutôt 5 mai de la pelouse auditeurs ça
veut dire habitat 'million british
thermal units c'est la façon de compter
le gaz naturel dans les unités
internationales et donc les qatari qui
espèrent que leur galles leur gaz sont
dépendants du détroit d'ormuz les trois
dames où ce qui est et qui pourraient
être bloqués par les iraniens et donc
ils se sont posé la question d'enlever
cette dépendance est de pouvoir exporter
leur gaz vers l'europe par pipeline et
donc quand on n'est pas 150000 pays pour
passer du qatar à l'europe se plaint de
ce seuil soit par l'irak soit par la
syrie est donc en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que bachar al-assad
était assez proche est assez proche des
qatariens qui était c'est presque ses
meilleures amies premier investisseur
étranger
en syrie le qatar jusqu'en 2011 et il
avait discuté en 2009 d'un projet de
faire passer un tuyau qui irait du qatar
arabie saoudite jordanie syrie de
turquie est d'ailleurs à l'époque bachar
al assad s'entendait très bien avec cars
2 gagnent on le surnommait son petit
frère et puis et puis ce ce projet n'a
pas plu bien évidemment aux russes qui
voyait un concurrent pour le gaz sur
l'europe et n'a pas non plus plus aux
iraniens et chara ça détend alaouite
donc qui est une minorité des chiites a
finalement décidé de mettre fin à ce
projet pour faire un réseau de gazoducs
avec l'iran et en 2011 du jour au
lendemain les relations se sont coupés
entre le qatar le qatar qui devait et
suite à cet accord apporte et la
protection à la syrie une protection
militaire un peu comme les états unis la
porte et l'arabie saoudite du jour au
lendemain et bien leurs armes au lieu de
les donner au régime ils les ont donné
aux rebelles
francis
sur la syrie alors il ya deux aspects
d'une part les ressources énergétiques
de la syrie et puis et la possibilité
pour la syrie d'être un pays de transit
pour
notamment du gaz venant d'ailleurs sur
le premier point il faut quand même bien
garder à l'esprit que la syrie ce n'est
pas un gros détenteur de réserves
pétrolières et gazières
l'irak c'est évidemment tout à fait
autre chose l'irak est un géant
pétrolier en termes de réserves la syrie
avant évidemment la guerre de 2011
disons jusqu'au début de cette décennie
était un petit producteur de pétrole et
de gaz donc il faut pas en faire sur ce
plan là sur le banc des réserves il faut
pas en faire un enjeu stratégique et
liées à l'énergie sur le plan de la
question du transit ce qu'évoquait
nicolas
nicolas rappeler que le qatar est
aujourd'hui le premier exportateur
mondial de gaz naturel liquéfié
à partir de leurs installations de
liquéfaction arras la fan sur le golf
ils peuvent approvisionner le monde
entier en tout cas là où il ya des
besoins évidemment temps du gaz en
fonction de compétitivité par rapport à
d'autres fournisseurs
le marché européen le marché asiatique
le marché nord américain même si ce
marché va se fermer parce que les états
unis ont une production de gaz grâce à
l'orgasme convoi celles qui augmentent
ils sont devenus le premier producteur
de gaz au monde devant la russie
ils sont maintenant autosuffisant en gaz
ils ont commencé à exporter du gaz
naturel liquéfié en février 2016 et ils
vont devenir très rapidement un
exportateur net de gaz donc ils ont plus
besoin garderont des importations venant
du canada qui est le grand voisin mais
voilà ils vont devenir exportateur net
de gaz dont il y aura plus beaucoup de
gaz à exporter ou plus du tout vers les
états unis restera les marchés
asiatiques et européens
donc le qatar s'est doté à coup de
dizaines de milliards de dollars de
plusieurs trains géant de liquéfaction
les plus grands au monde arras la fan
pour pouvoir exporter du gaz naturel
liquéfié par tous et par conséquent pour
eux la valeur stratégique d'un gazoduc à
travers la syrie c'est pas très
important du tout on croit que entre le
qatar et la syrie le seule différence
est cette histoire du gaz mais on oublie
qu'il ya quelques autres petits
problèmes entre eux notamment la
question de l'iran la syrie et au sein
du monde arabe le pays qui a les
relations les plus étroites avec l'iran
et c'est d'ailleurs l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles la syrie n'est pas
vraiment en odeur de sainteté si je puis
dire aux yeux d'autres pays arabes
notamment les pays arabes du golfe donc
je crois que c'est d'abord on est dans
une région le moyen-orient qui est une
éponge à pétrole et à gaz et nous
parlons aujourd'hui de pétrole énergie
géopolitique il ya évidemment souvent
des raisons des relations très étroites
pardon entre pétrole gaz géopolitique
stratégie dans cette région pour autant
il ne faut pas penser que l'énergie y
compris pétrole et gaz peut expliquer
tout ce qui se passe dans cette région
là il ya aussi des dynamiques qui n'ont
rien à voir avec l'énergie eon pour ce
qui concerne la syrie je crois qu'il
faut pas trop s'attarder sur des
scénarios dans lesquels l'énergie sur un
petit peu le luxe makina oui je suis là
sur la semaine il s'affiche tout de
suite la pression sur la syrie est
effectivement la syrie est pas un un des
plus grands producteurs de pétrole dans
la région ceci étant la petit bien c'est
un petit soldat ceci étant dit c'était
un petit nathan les produits plus grand
chose ils ont passé leur maximum de
production
au début dé à la fin des années 90 il
faut avoir en tête que sur le
financement de l'état syrien
l'argent qui venait des exportations du
pétrole représentait 40% du budget au
début des années 2000 à la fin des
années 2000 on était à 25%
du fait qu'ils ont passé ce maximum de
production et donc ils ont quand même dû
trouver de l'argent ailleurs
comment est ce qu'on trouve de l'argent
ailleurs eh bien ça s'appelle les impôts
ça s'appelle des rues de réductions de
subventions aux prix de l'énergie et ça
je suis d'accord que ça n'est pas le
facteur principal mais c était un
facteur qui s'est ajoutée en plus dans
cette région en plus notamment des
crises qu'on a pu avoir climatiques qui
ont un impact très fort sur les sur
l'agriculture les productions locales de
céréales il rappelle souvent que la
différence entre une guerre civile et où
tout va bien c'est trois repas par jour
une des raisons qui a engendré les
printemps arabes que ce soir quand il
n'y a plus lourde ont eu lieu les
chevaux se battent actuellement philippe
on va passer à la chine à l'asie je
voudrais votre point de vue sur la
sécurisation décollé du col et perles et
ainsi que la mer de chine
alors sur le collier de perles est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'est
le collier de perles en fait c'est un un
maillage de point d'appui sur des porcs
qui vont de la chine continentale aura
côtière jusqu'au
golfe arabo persique
j'appuie deal
il port mais l'idée c'est d'avoir des
ports qui vous permet de faire escale
pour les tankers pour ce que vous voulez
voir voir
installer peut-être avec l'accord des
pays concernés
quand j'entends des stands et
sécurisation du collier de perles
j'entendais sécurisation américaine du
collier de perles qui à mon sens la
principale route énergétique de la chine
est ce que vous en pensez
je pense pas que les américains
s'intéressent de très près aux colliers
de perles en soit aussi depuis 2009 oui
mais après les affaires stratégiques du
ministère dont il faut il faut il s'est
produit très chaud le discours et les
actes les etats-unis ont cette vision
depuis l'administration obama avec le
pivot asiatique donc on est bien
d'accord c'est
la nouvelle orientation stratégique des
états unis par rapport à ce qui était
auparavant plutôt une relation
transatlantique
une telle qu'on l'a connue
maintenant les chinois n'ont pas les
moyens
dans l'immédiat de négocier
des bases
puissante
si on inclut quelques l'âge d'homme il
faut distinguer un peu les cas de figure
les maldives ou ou
le bangladesh va c'est pas gwadar
justement au pakistan godard c'est une
ville chinoise un port chinois construit
par des chinois habité par des chinois
c'est vraiment un
point de fixation
concrets qui peut amener toutes sortes
de projets ensuite ce qui sera pas le
cas des autres points d'appui qui eux
sont plus on va dire des points d'appui
maritime
pour la mer de chine qu'est ce que vous
pensez des revendications millénaire ou
millénariste des chinois concernant la
mer de chine bon c'est pas nouveau
chose qu'on peut dire en gros ils ont
commencé à revendiquer la fin des angles
de meuf qui laisse en gros presque
jusqu'à l'indonésie enfin ça a été un
peu plus au nord ont rejoint la phase de
l'australie c'est peut-être pour ça que
ça explique le contrat de 50 milliards
des australiens à vouloir des sous
marins oui ça notamment mais bon les
américains ont installé une base à
darwin donc au nord de l'australie
j'ai 500 hommes le croit donc c'est pas
non plus énorme est ce que l'on pensait
que chez moi s'attendent à une guerre
dans la région est est ce que c'est pour
ça qu'ils construisent des porte-avions
fixe par l'intermédiaire d' il crée de
2,2 rien qu'est ce que vous en pensez
les la stratégie militaire chinoise a
changé depuis on va dire ces dix
dernières années d'abord il ya un effort
militaire en termes budgétaires qui n'a
cessé d'augmenter mais quand on part
celui les calculs ni à celui de la chine
il n'y a pas photo auquel volume la
chine qui avait voulu des états unis aux
états unis
je vois les états unis c'est plus de 10
fois le budget de la défense chinois
donc
c'est pas ils sont pas dans la même
catégorie très clairement les états unis
ont ce différentes flotte sur tous les
océans avec des porte avions des unités
de projection les chinois viennent de
sortir leur premier porte avions donc on
part de 2,01 les chinois partent de rien
et en plus ils n'ont peut-être pas la
dernière technologie
en termes de compétitivité par rapport à
ce qu'ils font les américains qui
continuent d'investir donc
je sais que c'est un fantasme très très
européen voire occidentales ce conflit
chine etats unis
maintenant la chine depuis des décennies
son principal
axe stratégique c'était de rendre son
pays inexpugnable qu'on ne puisse pas
l'envahir donc c'est une stratégie
exclusivement défensive où la raison a
pas de besoin de porte avions puisque
notre ambition c'est pas d'aller se
projeter
à l'extérieur bon il faisait quelques
incursions en territoire voisin comme au
vietnam pendant
quelques petites escarmouches avec la
russie aussi sur le fleuve amour enfin
bon en gros c'était on est chez nous et
personne ne viendra chez nous
maintenant c'est un peu différent
puisque la chine en train de redevenir
une puissance globale dont je sais que
ces exportations sont très importantes
que donc les flux de marchandises vont
être de plus en plus importants alors ça
c'est une extrapolation sur quel type de
scénario de consommation mondiale parce
que l'exportation chinoise est en train
de baisser le système financier chinois
est en train de se casser la gueule ils
ont injecté à peu près 40 ou 50 points
pour un pib dans leurs économies pour
maintenir les choses à flot ils font
face à une fuite de capitaux
extraordinaire depuis clan bourse aux
quêtes oui mais bon ça si vous voulez
c'est les aléas de l'économie au sens
large et de la situation chinoise en
particulier
on peut pas dire
que le
les problèmes financiers de la chine
aujourd'hui vont conditionner
l'évolution de sa politique dans les
années où les décennies qui viennent
il faut savoir que les états la fin la
chine est en train de basculer d'une
économie
de production industrielle ou saas est
une c'est un dogme qui est souvent que
le porter de la mutation de la chine sur
les entreprises au service les choses
comme ça notamment mais pas seulement et
parce que aussi il va bien falloir que
l'ifri
il bascule d'exportations vers la
consommation intérieure bon ça sera pas
non plus là encore 2
d'un trait de plume ça prendra du temps
ça poserait des problèmes beaucoup de
problèmes peut-être en terme de chômage
sur investissement sûr que c'était autre
chose
néanmoins
là encore
quand on suit un peu l'évolution de la
politique chinoise le président xi
jinping actuellement au pouvoir est en
train de totalement noyauté
l'appareil d'état il a mis des âmes a lu
partout et
si demain il ya trop de contestations
comme il ya eu des jacqueries comme il
ya eu des rires des révoltes d'à peu
près 1000 milles
de long terme enfin la menace est un
grand pays beaucoup d'habitants donc
tout est relatif broutilles à paris
l'inscription prendre aux manifestations
chez tous ces 3 66 millions d'habitants
je sais pas combien ça serait bon
bref je pense que l'appareil d'état
chinois pour uccle parti communiste
puisse garder les rênes du pouvoir là je
ne veux pas comment il pourrait en être
autrement en tout cas sauf à faire des
extrapolations
un peu délirante bon qu'a toujours
l'armée la re que ces cours les
extrapolations déviante bas un
effondrement du système qu'elle fonde
quel système du parti communiste
puis celui qui tient les rênes et par
contre il ya remise enfin reprise en
main du pc on va dire par le pouvoir
central à pékin avec les campagnes anti
corruption avec tout ce qu'on veut bon
alors ça ça va évidemment c je vais vous
mettre une petite pause francis
l'asie la chine la mer de chine
toussaint a effectivement comme la
comme l'a rappelé philippe
on avait donc beaucoup évoqué du côté à
washington ce basculement militaire et
stratégique vers l'asie
du fait du poids de l'asie dans la
population mondiale dans l'économie
mondiale c'est l'une des grandes
orientations stratégiques de
l'administration obama depuis depuis le
début depuis ce le premier mandat du
président obama
et puis et donc il voulait le faire
progressivement bien sûr il ya eu des
problèmes qui n'avaient pas forcément
envisagé comme souvent d'une part en
europe la crise russo ukrainienne et ses
conséquences et la nécessité de
réassurer de rassurer par dont l'allié
européen et et deuxièmement au
moyen-orient l'état islamique avec la
syrie l'irak en afrique du nord un peu
la libye et c'est ce qui fait que le
président obama et ses conseillers n'ont
pas pu à ce jour et ça va pas changer
demain
mettre en oeuvre comme il le souhaitait
ce réajustement stratégique sur le plan
militaire vers l'asie
ça reste dans leur attention à moyen et
à long terme pour les raisons évoquées
mais il a bien fallu renvoyer au
contraire des troupes vers le moyen
orient que l'administration obama
souhaitait au contraire quitté quitté de
façon relativement au sens de troupes au
sol et puis l'europe vous voulez alléger
le dispositif le dispositif militaire
par rapport à la mer de chine évidemment
ce qui se passe en europe alléger le
dispositif militaire américain de
l'américain ça a été multiplié par
quatre le budget steiner oui avait
justement ça c'est la conséquence de la
crise grecque en mai par rapport aux
intentions du président obama et de ses
proches conseillers sur le plan
diplomatique il y avait vraiment la
volonté d'alléger le dispositif
militaire américain en europe et le
moyen orient pour aller vers l'asie
sur la mer de chine
du côté des états unis on dit toujours
il faut que ces problèmes soient réglés
pacifiquement on ne prend pas position
sur les revendications territoriales de
la chine de x2 y met ce qu'on veut c'est
que les gens se mettent autour d'une
table et discutent et n'emploie pas la
force la menace de la force et des
gesticulations militaires pour faire
peur et pour
conquérir une partie d'une partie du
gâteau ça permet évidemment aux états
unis de resserrer leurs relations avec
plusieurs des pays de la région qui ne
sont pas particulièrement très rassuré
aux ambitions chinoises y compris le
vietnam ce qui historiquement est bien
sûr on voit d'ailleurs venir depuis
quelques années ce rapprochement y
compris militaires stratégiques disons
stratégique
américano vietnamien mais ce qui se
passe en mer de chine l'attitude de la
chine pousse plusieurs pays alors
washington a des alliés depuis longtemps
nazis mais ce qui n'était pas forcément
ses grands alliés se disent à tout
prendre je préfère me rapprocher d'eux
les ennemis me désole c'est un grand
classique depuis machiavel sana parle et
puis du côté de la chine également et
gars cette dépendance croissante du pays
vis-à-vis des importations pétrolières
la chine est pourtant un gros producteur
de pétrole
c'est le la chine fait partie des cinq
ou six premiers producteurs mondiaux de
pétrole ce qui n'est quand même pas rien
en matière de production de pétrole on a
d'abord le super trio etats unis russie
arabie saoudite par ordre décroissant en
termes de production de pétrole
aujourd'hui et ensuite on à loin
derrière on a un deuxième groupe de
trois pays qui sont canada irak chine
avec entre 4 millions 1,4 million et
demi de barils par jour pour chacun de
ces pays les trois premiers c'est plus
de 10 millions de barils par jour pour
chaque 1 etats unis russie arabie
saoudite donc la chine est quand même un
grand producteur mondial de pétrole mais
sa production n'augmente plus depuis pas
mal de temps elle est à dire stable
alors que sa consommation elle galope
parce que sa consommation est lié à sa
croissance économique à son
développement à son industrialisation au
développement des transports automobiles
sur son territoire et l'écart se creuse
chaque année entre une production
chinois stable une consommation qui
augmente et donc de plus en plus la
chine doit faire face à
ce ce gap cet écart entre consommation
et production en apportant de plus en
plus de pétrole et ça c'est un facteur
qui préoccupe les dirigeants chiites de
cette année un plateau de production
nicolas meilhan sur la chine est ce que
la chine a atteint un plateau de
production au niveau de son pétrole et
que c'est pour ça qu'ils allaient obligé
de
importés de la chine a toujours été très
pragmatique sur les questions
énergétiques sur les questions du
pétrole effectivement on voit depuis un
certain nombre d'années que la
production chinoise autour de 4 millions
de barils par jour n'augmente plus mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est l'heure
nous pas de capacités de projection
militaire mais ils ont une capacité de
production économique et les accords qui
passe avec un certain nombre de pays qui
sont les fournisseurs de la chine en
pétrole premier fournisseur la russie
depuis le début l'année vous avez
ensuite l'arabie saoudite et vous avez
un certain nombre de pays comme l'angola
comme oman
comme l'irak aussi
la chine qui après les après la guerre
en irak a raflé un certain nombre de
concessions au nez des des pétroliers
européens et américains sur le pétrole
de l'irak et ils ont un pragmatisme
extrêmement important ils savent que
leur croissance économique future dépend
de cet approvisionnement de cette
sécurité est d'ailleurs quelque chose
d'intéressant depuis que les prix du
pétrole ont baissé de presque 70 % la
consommation et la demande chinoise n'a
pas baissé
pourquoi parce que la chine achète tout
le pétrole disponible pour le stocker
alors c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas
aujourd'hui les trois mois de réserves
stratégiques qu'ont les pays de l' ocde
mais l'an dernier cinq cent mille barils
par jour étaient achetés par les chinois
pour le stocker d'abord le stocker dans
des réservoirs en surface et ensuite
recréer quasiment des puits de pétrole
artificiel le crre le stocker de manière
souterraine pour reconstituer ses stocks
je crois que l'an dernier il avait
atteint 200 millions de baril et que
leur objectif c'est 500 millions à
horizon 2020 donc ils savent beaucoup
plus que nous les européens que leurs
futurs leur croissance et le maintien de
sur leur système qui dépendent ces taux
de croissance dépend du pétrole il y à
cette politique de stockage stratégique
que vient des causes évoquées à juste
titre nicolas qu'elle est une des
priorités de la politique énergétique
chinoise il y a il a évoqué également
une diversification des
approvisionnements avec notamment pas
uniquement mais la montée en puissance
de la russie le kazakhstan d'autres pays
l'afrique l'angola etc il y a aussi une
politique de contrôle d'actifs
pétroliers le gouvernement chinois donne
pour mission aux compagnies pétrolières
étatiques et dans les trois principales
la cnpc la china national petroleum
corporation sinopec et la cnpc china
national offshore oil corporation
d'aller dans le monde entier en tout cas
l'a eu il ya du pétrole de prendre des
participations dans des actifs
pétroliers
pour avoir droit à une part de la
production qui si besoin est pour être
acheminés vers le marché chinois pour
contribuer à la sécurisation des
approvisionnements et il ya aussi une
politique de diversification énergétique
alors il ya le problème du charbon la
chine il faut jamais l'oublier
consomment la moitié du charbon consommé
dans le monde à elle toute seule mais ça
pose bien sûr quelques petits problèmes
environnementaux pollution locale
considérable avec sans doute des
centaines de milliers de morts
prématurées en chine chaque année et
puis contribution au changement
climatique
c'est pas pour ça qu'ils vont abandonner
les charbons parce que c'est leur
charbon c'est une ressource nationale
mais ils peuvent pas continuer pour m
ils ne le feront pas à aller développer
le charbon donc ils vont faire monter en
puissance le gaz naturel y compris en
apportant du gaz naturel liquéfié
justement ce qu'ils ont commencé à faire
il développe et ils vont continuer à
développer les énergies renouvelables
l'efficacité énergétique donc il faut un
petit peu feu de tout bois mais c'est
une de leurs préoccupations majeures en
termes de politique énergétique et bien
entendu politique énergétique sécurité
des approvisionnements on est en pleine
stratégie en pleine géopolitique bien
sûr philippe et jeu juste pour compléter
mon produit bonne
stratégie d'approvisionnement chinoise
donc comme le disait justement
francis ils achètent des droits sur des
gisements
il rachète départ d'actifs sur des
compagnies étrangères déjà présente
prendre l'exemple de repsol au brésil où
ils ont créé une joint-venture ou
la chine prend 40 % des actifs de repsol
au brésil et repsol c'est la deuxième
compagnie en termes de superficie des
gisements à développer ou déjà octroyés
derrière petrobras la compagnie
nationale ça me fait penser tout à fait
la même démarche que l'iran avait eu
avec swift quand il s'était fait
expulser de chez swift ils sont usés
diversifié absolument
leurs finances pour éviter ça les
chinois font un peu préparé c'était
qu'ils achètent des parts à côté pour
pouvoir
parer les assiettes des actifs soit sous
forme financière je suis en fait ce sera
toujours repsol opérateur ce sera
toujours un truc qui fera le job on va
dire par contre sur la production à
venir ils prendront 40% autre cas de
figure toujours en amérique latine le
venezuela le venezuela n'a pas les
moyens et vu la crise qu'ils traversent
encore plus aujourd'hui qu'hier de
financer ses investissements pétroliers
à travers la compagnie nationale pdvsa
est-ce que vous pouvez rappeler juste
pour nos auditeurs qu'est ce qui se
passe au venezuela m'ont mise à part
l'inflation aucune écoute et aux
fonctionnaires travaillent depuis
toujours par jour et que certains
fonctionnaires faut pas exagérer il faut
se souvient parti qu'en fonctionnement
je présume que les ordures ménagères
continuer d'être ramassés je
le souhaite pour
enfin
bon il se passe une crise économique qui
était prévisible pourquoi prix
prévisible parce que quand on vous avez
un cours du brut enfin 57 90 ouais
vraiment fait recette en juillet c'était
2011 juillet 2011 donc je viens de 8,8
de 8 oui avant la crise certains là
comme ça qu'on lui fait subir à chaque
fois avant la crise juste avant la crise
et donc la chute donc
quand vous avez des recettes budgétaires
de s'étendre là pour un pays qui exporte
en gros pour 90% vécu au dessus de
l'anglais ils ont vécu au-dessus de
leurs moyens ce qui a financé les
missions les fameuses missions de goût
de chavez qui l ont permis de sortir un
certain nombre de millions de
vénézuéliens de la pauvreté donc là on
peut discuter du bien fondé de la chose
la méthode de financement néanmoins bon
le but en lui même est plutôt louable
maintenant ce qu'on faisait avec 100
millions enfin 100 milliards de
dhs ensemble il y aura un baril à 100
dollars on peut plus le faire avec un
baril à 40 du coup
quand on essaie de maintenir ce genre de
subventions ou de
2,2
davantage sociaux si l'on peut dire est
que vous n'avez plus rien pour les
financer votre économie plonge votre
monnaie des vols complètement comme il
s'agit en plus du venezuela un pays qui
importe l'essentiel de ses biens de
consommation vous avez plus de papier
toilette imaginer pénurie de papier
toilette aujourd'hui maintenant c'est la
vierge unique maintenant c'est la bière
bon la bière qui est la boisson
nationale au venezuela ils peuvent plus
importer le l'orge parce que là encore
les prix ont augmenté alors que leurs
recettes ont diminué donc on va vers un
système et sans compter qu'en plus
certains produits sont deux premiers en
suisse sont subventionnés et donc son
font l'objet d'un trafic avec la
colombie parce qu'évidemment c'est moins
cher au venezuela vous pouvez le
revendre plus cher en colombie qui fait
que c'est un puits sans fond et donc le
système économique venezuela en train de
s'effondrer complètement mais je voulant
revenir donc au pétrole et à la chine
puisqu'il ne pouvait pas financer
précisément leurs investissements et
qu'ils avaient par ailleurs sans doute
besoin de recettes annexes ça c'est
moins 10
la chine a donné à plusieurs reprises on
va prêter des dizaines de milliards de
dollars
gagés sur du pétrole à venir donc ce que
il en est de façon on dit là encore que
le vénézuélien après les et les
relations un peu houleuse qu'il y avait
eu entre les états unis george bush et
le venezuela
étrangement ça a pas énormément
ont fait chuter les exportations du
venezuela vers les états unis
exportations pétrolières elles ont
progressivement diminué au profit de la
chine justement il ya un système de
bascule
parce que les vénézuéliens sont bien
obligés de rembourser une partie de
leurs prêts ont peut-être en pétrole il
coûte 60 milliards d'euros 60 milliards
d'euros
les prêts les prêts de la chine à
l'argentine ça c'est l'exemple
exactement les prés de la chine à venise
eu hélas mais effectivement ce que fait
c'est ce que des philippins ce qui se
passe avec le venezuela a été fait avec
un certain nombre de pays j'ai en tête
l'afghanistan où 80% des investissements
directs étrangers sont chinois bien
évidemment l'afrique sur toutes les
matières toutes les céréales toute
l'agriculture les chinois ont besoin ont
besoin ils sont pas autosuffisants et
donc ont besoin ont mis la main sur un
certain nombre de pays en afrique et de
régions où ils arrivent ils construisent
des villes et il récupère et récupère
toutes les céréales pour pouvoir
s'approvisionner donc qu'il ya quelque
chose d'intéressant avec la chine dont
on pourrait s'inspirer en europe c'est
cette volonté alors sur
l'agroalimentaire c'est vrai que nous en
france mais assez bien lotis donc on est
autosuffisant en tout cas dans tout ce
qui est céréales mais sur le pétrole et
l'énergie on dépend encore à 30% de la
russie que ce soit sur le gaz mais aussi
sur le pétrole même si le lien sur le
pétrole et +10 tendue puisque ça
marchait qui est mondial ce qu'on n'a
pas dit tout à l'heure et je voulais
ajouter c'est que sur la partie énergie
effectivement après les ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine l'europe s'est dit on
dépend trop de la russie il faut que
nous diversifions des approvisionnements
et en même temps vous aviez aux états
unis cette révolution qui a eu sur le
pétrole et le gaz de roche mère qui
comme le disait francis fait
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont autosuffisants
sur le gaz sur le pétrole il n en porte
encore 40% il faut aussi noter que
depuis cette révolution il importe plus
aujourd'hui de pétrole de l'arabie
saoudite qu'avant la révolution il
importe moins de pétrole plus si vous
êtes passé deux ans je me suis amusé à
regarder les importations pétrolières
américaines donc de l'arabie saoudite de
l'arabie saoudite adacore effectivement
ils emportent ya 800 mille barils du
nigeria qu'ils n'apportent plus puisque
c'était la même qualité un de light
sweet crude mais donc met donc les
américains on avait un intérêt si vous
voulez à ce que les européens se fâche
avec les russes pour pouvoir leur vendre
leur gaz ils le font déjà en partie hier
énergie vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui
allumez votre chaudière au gaz et vous
chauffer au gaz schiste est aussi sur le
pétrole parce qu'il pensait il
probablement à tort qu'un jour il allait
être indépendant terme de pétrole alors
il en exporte ils ont enlevé le
l'interdiction d'exporter qui gâte qui
date du premier choc pétrolier mais ça
c'est pour des raisons de deux
raffineries et le fait que le pétrole
qui produisent aux états unis ne peut
pas être raffiné là bas car ils ont des
raffineries qui est plus adapté du
pétrole extra-lourd et donc les
américains avaient un intérêt à ce que
les européens se fâche chantant de moins
bien et que les russes alors que c'est
l'allié naturel la russie avec l'europe
pour les peaux les années qui viennent
que ce soit sur l'énergie ou sur un
certain nombre d'industries comme
l'aérospatiale etc je vais passer
peut-être les
avants le chiffre est juste un chiffre
parce qu'il est je pense qu il est vrai
et il est très spectaculaire en 2005
les importations pétrolières des
etats-unis
coupvray 60 % de leur consommation
nationale donc un taux de dépendance
élevée
aujourd'hui on est à un peu plus de 20 %
21 22% donc en une dizaine d'années
leur taux de dépendance
vis-à-vis des importations pétrolières a
été divisée par 3 c'est un vaisseau du
consiel soutenabilité
en tout cas on n'est pas dans le court
terme on est au minimum on est dans un
moyen long terme la question c'est
jusqu'à quand ça vient en grande partie
cette diminution très fortes de leur
taux de dépendance s'explique de deux
façons d'une part une consommation qui
n'augmentent plus voir qu a même décliné
un petit peu consommation pétrolière
intérieure des états unis la cession est
une production pétrolière en forte
hausse depuis 2008 du fait des pétroles
dit non conventionnel et ça réduit
évidemment considérablement l'écart
entre la consommation et la production
à quelques années enfin disons à la fin
des années 2020 2007 2008 les états unis
et est le premier consommateur mondial
de pétrole le troisième producteur
mondial de pétrole est le premier
importateur mondial de pétrole
aujourd'hui ils sont toujours le premier
consommateur mais ils sont le premier
producteur et son le deuxième
importateur mondial de pétrole derrière
la chine qui est passé devant les états
unis par rapport à ces le lien avec ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure
ils ont d'immenses réserves de gaz non
conventionnels les états unis ils ont
des réserves importantes de pétrole non
conventionnel mais sur la base des
données qu'on a aujourd'hui on peut pas
dire ils ont des réserves immenses de
pétrole non conventionnel d'où votre
question combien de temps est-ce que ça
peut durer pour le gaz très longtemps
sans aucun doute pour le pétrole le
département de l'énergie des états unis
dit on a en tout cas une dynamique de
progression notre notre production
pétrolière jusque vers 2025 là on voit à
peu près clair à cet horizon là
ensuite on est prudent ensuite point
d'interrogation il n'est pas sûr que les
états unis aient des réserves
pétrolières suffisante c'est pas le
moyen-orient c'est pas l'arabie saoudite
en dépit du non conventionnelles
mais ensuite c'est ça c'est sur la base
de l'état actuel de nos connaissances
les compagnies pétrolières vont
évidemment continuer à se développer à
explorer à faire progresser les
techniques mais pour l'instant
disons que jusque vers la moitié de la
décennie prochaine
les états unis vont être dans une
situation pétrolières qui sera fort
bonne avec de moins en moins
d'importations
au delà il faut être prudent et ne pas
forcément se précipiter dès aujourd'hui
pour faire des prévisions au delà de
2025 2030 philippe je vais vous donner
la parole concernant l arctique
l'arctique on en est où
nulle part
fait froid
et les pingouins
non c'est à dire qu'elle est
les grandes compagnies qui avaient des
permis notamment au nord de l'alaska
ont tenté de faire des premiers forages
et on savait que la lapel
propice à ce genre de forage est très
très limité mois d'été et en septembre
il faudrait alors tous tous terminés
donc on sait le catch elle notamment qui
a eu pas mal de déboires et donc on dit
pour l'instant angèle ans sans jeu de
mots mais donc vu les prix par ailleurs
actuel il est sûr que l'article va pas
être une priorité pour la plupart des
compagnies qui ont aidé à partir de quel
prix c'est intéressant l'arctique à
l'article pour l'instant je dis on n'est
pas très opérationnelle sur sûre on n'a
pas beaucoup de d'éléments de
comparaison les russes font des choses
d'antan dans l'arctique soviétique
mais on n'a pas des éléments
je dirais très fiable et avec du recul
pour savoir combien ça coûte réellement
on sait que ça va coûter très cher parce
que c'est des infrastructures qui vont
être par définition très spécial et
l'acheminement ça va se passer comment
par exemple si je vous dis que le
réchauffement climatique avec le
permafrost pour poser un oléoduc c'est
compliqué comment ça va se passer s'il
ya les réchauffements il y aura
peut-être moins de permafrost oui mais
les sols sont instables dont il y aura
les bâtons durant les batailles âge
marine donc là je redonne la parole tout
de suite un
passage du nord ouest
donc là les redevances carences et
non
sur l'arctique je crois qu' il y à déjà
aujourd'hui et depuis des années une
réalité
de développement et d'exploitation
pétrolière et gazière en arctique
c'est le cas aux états unis avec
l'alaska qui est un état producteur de
pétrole et gaz depuis très longtemps
depuis des dizaines d'années c'est le
cas d'une partie du nord du canada c'est
le cas d'une partie de la russie c'est
le cas d'une partie de la norvège et
puis il ya les ambitions danoise avec le
croyait de landes mais là on est dans
l'exploration donc l'arctique c'est déjà
une réalité aujourd'hui pétrolière et
gazière depuis pas mal d'années s'est
pas seulement l'avenir en disant qu'est
ce qu'on va faire de l'arctique est ce
qu'on va aller trouver du pétrole oui
bien sûr c'est le cas déjà dépassé pour
ça c'est pour ça qu'on a vu les
supertankers entrer dans la construction
à grande vitesse là je ne sais pas
combien de projets de super bateau
d'acheminement de
les supertankers s'est pas uniquement
par rapport à la clique c'est pas une
séance par rapport au transport
pétrolier de fos mokrane mais évidemment
ça peut alors erratique sa demande
certaines spécificités parce qu'il faut
parfois il faut des brise glaces il faut
donc là on est sur les cookies évoqué
philippe les difficultés technologiques
et les coûts mais l'arctique c'est déjà
une réalité pétrolière et gazière
aujourd'hui bien sûr c'est pour
l'instant très peu exploité par rapport
au potentiel on ne peut pas chiffrer
mais qui est certainement très
importants
mais là je reviens à ce que disait
philippe il ya la question des prix de
la rentabilité qui capitale avec un prix
à 100 dollars par baril les compagnies
pétrolières se disaient oui bien sûr on
va développer de nouveaux projets en
plus de ce qui existe déjà et il y en a
déjà un certain nombre mais on va
développer de plus en plus de projets
dans cette partie du monde qui est
encore l'un des rares zones mondiales
qui est très peu explorée papa inexploré
mais très peu exploré avec un prix
aujourd'hui on est sur 45 47 en janvier
on était à moins de 30 c'est clair que
c'est pas la priorité pour des raisons
de rentabilité
on y lit a eu le pétrole et le gaz non
conventionnel aux états unis qui ont
largement changé la donne au niveau
mondial plus le canada avec le pétrole
extrait des sables bitumineux ce qui
fait qu'on s'est même trouvé avec un
excédent pétrole au plan mondial c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a fait chuter les prix
largement donc quand vous avez trop de
pétrole sur le marché des prix très bas
et encore plein de choses à faire dans
d'autres régions du monde y compris en
amérique du nord pour une compagnie
pétrolière qui agit normalement de façon
à peu près rationnelle vous dites-vous
malartic bien sûr je perds pas ça de vue
la preuve c'est que souvent j'y suis
déjà mais c'est pas la région
prioritaire pour de nouveaux
développements dans les prochaines
années certes tous et en termes de
calendrier ça reste évidemment un enjeu
stratégique important pour l'industrie
pétrolière mais à moyen et long terme
est plutôt qu à court moyen terme mais
j'ai faut compléter sur des finitions
géopolitiques autour de l'arctique
on entend souvent dire qu'il peut y
avoir des conflits pétroliers sur les
revendications territoriales des uns et
des autres c'est assez faux dans la
mesure où la plupart des gisements
pétroliers en tout cas sont le long des
côtes et sont pas sur des zones
disputées en terme de conflit
territorial entre les pays riverains de
la zone donc lvmh et la russie
on finit par trouver un autre vendeur de
bahreïn sans fin et avec quelques mini
conflit par contre
il faut le dire aussi c'est
l'essentiel des ressources en
hydrocarbures
de la zone arctique c'est d'abord du gaz
beaucoup plus de gaz et de pétrole et
donc dans la situation actuelle c'est
moins intéressant là aussi je vais vous
poser une dernière question à chacun la
question classique de notre chaîne
youtube il faut donner un conseil pour
les jeunes générations alors francis la
connaît déjà nicolas la donner des ailes
à la connaît déjà alors on va commencer
par philippe obama laissez moi le temps
de leur effectif
je l'appelle dépendants ont repris cher
on passe on passe sur nico nicolas
pardon
la question à n'ont pas la même réponse
que leur font attention je me fâche on
attend donc un conseil un conseil pour
les jeunes générations une bouteille à
la mer c'est exactement je pense que
depuis quinze ans le monde a changé
le monde est beaucoup plus petit avec le
développement d'internet et aujourd'hui
j'encouragerai les gens sur ces sujets
là qui sont compliqués qui sont le
pétrole et la géopolitique
c'est toujours important d'avoir un
certain nombre de différentes sources
pour croiser les informations et donc
les jeunes doivent aujourd'hui
s'approprier s'approprier la formation
se créent leurs propres médias en allant
chercher en allant lire différentes
sources et différents points de vue pour
recroiser les infos c'est ce que je fais
tous les jours dans mon métier et c'est
essentiel pour pouvoir se forger une
opinion et ne jamais
ne jamais prendre pour argent comptant
ce qu'on vous raconte francis
je serais tenté de tricher et de
reprendre ce que nicolas vient dire à
savoir qu' on a parlé bien sûr
aujourd'hui d'enjeux stratégiques dont
je géopolitiques liées à l'énergie et
bien sûr il y en a beaucoup c'est aussi
un enjeu démocratique l'énergie parce
que l'énergie ça concerne tout le monde
tout le monde est au minimum
utilisateurs énergie tous les jours 50
fois par jour
c'est ça ce sont des sujets extrêmement
importants qui pèsent sur les choix
politiques économiques ce qu'on a un
petit peu développés partiellement dans
cette danse à travers ce débat et je
crois que ce que nicolas vient dire sur
jeunes et moins jeunes d'ailleurs sur
l'appropriation par des personnes par
des groupes de personnes par des
sociétés de ces enjeux énergétiques
de leurs de leur poids de leurs
influences
s'emparer un sujet tout à fait essentiel
ça nous éloigne un petit peu des aspects
technico économiques qui sont très
importants mais je conclurai bien je
choisirais bien comme détail à la mer
effectivement ce ce rappel de
l'importance de l'énergie pour toutes
les sociétés du monde et donc dans les
enjeux démocratiques
liées à l'énergie à la connaissance de
ces enjeux et si possible à la maîtrise
de ses enjeux philippe seul ou presque
bon je rejoins mes deux petits camarades
sur le cloud le côté indispensable de
s'informer ils sont formées à
différentes sources de comparer les
sources pour se faire sa propre religion
et surtout échapper et c'est peut-être
là la principale mise en garde que je
voudrais
évoquer ici
faire attention aux courants doctrinaux
c'est à dire aux gens qui ont un
prêt-à-penser liés à des idées
du moment et ça on peut le comprendre
appuyé sur des courants politiques ou
autres
et qui malheureusement parce qu'ils sont
peut-être politiquement très très
impliqués ont tendance à pas toujours
avoir une vision très précise de la
réalité et choisir un petit plus qui
leur convient dans la porte qui leur
convient moins donc c'est pour ça que ça
rejoint le côté s'informer d'abord pour
éviter d'être ensuite au durcir son
esprit critique être sujet par objet
voilà en fait messieurs merci
[Musique]
dans
m
[Musique]